we have to make it harder for people to
be able to purchase weapons we have
people now who are on a terrorist watch
list who can't purchase a weapon I have
no issue with more extensive background
checks I have no issue with slowing down
purchases for people that show all the
basic warning signs we're gonna make
school safety the top priority we're
also going to work with the Congress and
leaders around the country to more
effectively give law enforcement tools
to deal with people suffering with
dangerous mental illness political
leaders weigh in in the wake of 17
students being gunned down in parkland
Florida in that latest school shooting
one of the worst that we have seen in
this country let's bring in our panel
now to talk about where we go from here
Tom Bevin RealClearPolitics co-founder
and publisher and Garen political
correspondent at the Washington Post and
Molly Hemingway the senior editor at The
Federalist so we have now Republicans
saying something needs to change we need
to do something in the wake of this but
we heard similar language after the Las
Vegas shooting and when which
Republicans seem to support this idea of
banning these bump stocks so and are we
are we getting close to critical mass
here that something will happen or will
it be talked about and then like we've
seen in the past it will fade away
certainly history suggests that there'll
be a moment here like there was with
bump stocks and then it will go away
that said I think that this really does
feel like there's a different current in
the water and I think we see evidence
that president Trump's he feels that
there's something different about about
this time to the main difference to me I
think is the these kids there it is
really hard to look away and really hard
to ignore 17 18 year olds who are
blaming adults blaming the president
blaming the political system blaming
both parties for not doing enough and I
if that level of action and political
engagement continues it's going to be
hard for everyone to look away Tom can
these students go up against the
entrenched beliefs and both sides of the
aisle here in Washington well they can I
think as Ann said they're pretty
effective communicators for their cause
the problem is
that it with these instance we always
see in hindsight what we should have
seen in foresight and you can go back
an interesting fact John the last three
mass shootings in Florida
Omar Mateen pulse nightclub June 2016
Fort Lauderdale Airport shooting in
January 2017 and this one all three
perpetrators were on the radar of the
FBI in fact the one who shot up the Fort
Worth Airport went into the FBI office
and said that he was being
mind-controlled by the CIA to clear you
know set all these crazy things and
still managed to get a gun go down there
and do this so the FBI I think really
did drop the ball not just in this
incident but in others and that's part
of the problem we we have the dots
they're all there was not able to
connect them molly one of the big
questions is where does President Trump
can come down on all of this and what is
the appropriate role that he should take
on let's listen what the Ohio Governor
John Kasich said he thinks the president
should do we need leadership out of the
executive this is a great opportunity
for common-sense steps that can be taken
just in the area of background checks of
course the president can lead on this
and should lead on this so the president
supports enhanced background checks but
really what he's supporting is to
enforce the laws that are already in the
books to make sure that federal
governments in the States report to this
ni CS criminal background check database
which they're not doing now so how much
leadership are we going to see out of
the problem people do seem to want
government action at times like this and
if they do care about government action
there are all these opportunities as Tom
pointed out then with the Florida
examples but also this is the third
shooting I can think of where there was
specific government failure in the
Charleston Church shooting the Texas
church shooting there was failure to put
people on the lists that would make it
so that they would be caught during a
background check here you had multiple
people giving specific credible
assessments that this guy was going to
do exactly what he did rather than put
new laws on the books that are not
followed I think that a great thing for
the government to do would actually be
to make sure that the laws that are on
the books the guidance that is on the
books is faithfully executed the brother
then have another thing that isn't
followed it seems like a simple thing to
just you know here's the law here's what
the last step you
i'ts everybody let's get together and
make sure that we are faithfully
adhering to the laws and where we're
sharing all of this information well
sure I mean this seems like a no-brainer
to me that the next system does have one
soft spot which is that states are not
compelled to turn over the information
and and what the corn and Murphy bill
would do is add incentives and
encouragement to states to do that so
that you would have a better collection
of information but I mean in this
particular instance there if if the FBI
had followed up if a number of other
potential fail-safes which are not
actually a law had bent had been in
place this guy might have been stopped
but there is one law that would have
prevented at least him doing exactly
what he ended up carrying out which is
an assault weapon ban he was able to
legally buy and an ar-15 which would not
have been the case fifteen years ago and
so I mean that is a high hurdle for for
Congress to consider taking up the
assault weapons ban again but certainly
you're gonna hear calls for it so the
FBI as you pointed out tom is being
called out for missing you know a very
big warning signal here and failing to
connect the dots Ohio Governor John
Kasich said that people should be held
accountable for that what what should
happen in your estimation if the FBI is
told at its headquarters that there is a
a credible threat against a school in
Florida and never passes that
information along to the local field
office well somebody should should be
suspended or lose their jobs potentially
that should that be the FBI director oh
I don't know that it necessarily has to
be the FBI director but certainly the
people who were fielded that information
failed to pass it on as was part of FBI
protocol they did not follow FBI
protocol there should be consequences
for that look I think the FBI could
actually undertake a broader
investigation about the cases that I
mentioned and others why they're not
able to connect the dots why they're not
able when they have people who have all
these red flags and warning signs when
one receives on a terrorist watch list
for two years they interviewed him and
they close the case took them off there
and he managed to commit the crime so
the FBI can do a lot of
internal investigation and perhaps come
up with you know some some ways of doing
things better in the future to try and
prevent these things from happening
because they keep happening